[Music]
welcome to the show
[Music]
came along
Jason life is amazing when it comes to
your family everything really come down
to communication all in your head about
it but don't forget about it just let it
out let's talk it out let's talk it out
let's talk it out let's talk it out
sit down
foreign
Happy Father's Day from Jay and Silent
Bob I'm Kevin Smith she's a muse
kids we are
it's like we're in the pandemic it's
like 20 20.
because me and the boy
the boy who will be Dad yes
um of a boy
as we've learned
I know I'm very excited we have some
names I want to throw some names at you
but I'll wait to get I know you're
chatting still but as we go on
it's interesting the names have been
become a really big thing because again
Logan was so easy it was like if we have
a boy we have a girl boom bottom line
name's gonna be Logan it was easy but
this one now we're like it's a boy we
gotta come up with names and then we're
still deciding about the circumcision uh
bro bro bro
is this how you [ __ ] you stamped me past
the nipples
I do you go right for the [ __ ] the life
always says you're like a high school
boy you are we gotta ease the audience
into conversation you're not like yo I
gotta cut the kid's [ __ ] and I need a
name
and he said boy and she's got four
months and I think welcome to Jay and
some button first let's explain
we sound like [ __ ] because we're zooming
at each other yes last for first two
episodes
uh we were in Los Angeles we recorded
like
while I was home from the tour pre-tour
and while I was home from the tour for a
minute
um
and they were bagged for a minute before
they saw the light of day now we're in
real time [ __ ] but in real time
I'm in New Jersey Jason Muse our native
home and native land by the way of both
me and [ __ ] father to Father himself
and father to be Jason Muse
um he is in California in Los Angeles at
his new palatial Hollywood estate nice
yes
um so this is the first time I'm seeing
you
in your where is this your new man cave
do you have a back house or something it
is it is the garage but it's it's
temporary like well sorry it's not
tomorrow this is where I'm going to be
doing what I'm doing now but we're going
to be renovating so but yes we've been
here about two months right now I have
this up trying to block but yes this is
the garage it's technically a two-car
garage you say this up trying to block
because remembering some people are just
listening to this Jason's referring to
it Superman
background we can see each other via
Zoom I don't know if we're gonna put up
the video and [ __ ] that's true we
haven't thought about it exactly but yes
it is a food if we want to promote this
[ __ ] and get some [ __ ] subscribers
maybe we should put up the video I would
love to talk right now Father's Day Jane
Silent Bob get extras with video of my
face going like this and then this and
then you get to see this this being a
fold away uh room divider or what have
you it's very nice I got it from comic
book man when Comic Book Men TV show
ended the guys from the office had this
to separate uh their desks from one
another and I was like oh my gosh it's a
Justice League it has dead shot one of
my favorite characters
um and so they gave it to me but anyway
it's something nice to put that kid you
hear that kids the rich get richer he
was given something he usually could
have bought for himself
and he's he rubbed it in all of our
faces
I begged him for it I thought I'd eat
this
um but I didn't know if I could find it
I was worried about finding it on Amazon
because it's so sweet again it has it's
two-sided right it has it has Hawk
there's a bunch of people listening
going I can't see [ __ ] why is this true
master of a decade old podcast called
Jane Silent Bob get old forgetting that
video prompts are for the [ __ ]
wealthy for the boots no no they're
going to want to see it because I talk
about it too much let me see let me see
and then they're going to subscribe when
they [ __ ] tune in they're like it's a
picture of Superman bro get over
yourself that's true
um I am uh still on tour
with clerks 3 there are two shows left
to do kids two only that's it Boston on
December 5th hot food on December 6th
and then we're done the clerks the
convenience tour is in the
[ __ ] history books at that point and
stuff and I want you
every night
destroy the audience the one of the
biggest [ __ ] Applause moments in all
movies when we enter the [ __ ] movie
it's crazy dude every night I I sit
there and live in Josh backstage and
conduct pretend to conduct the audience
like during the opening credits because
I know exactly where they [ __ ] cheer
and [ __ ] like that and when you and I
come out they're like what and I tell
them I tell the kids every night I'm
like here come their gods and then we
come on screen and they go [ __ ] ape
[ __ ] and I'm like and I do their compose
I've raised my hands into the air as if
I'm conducting the audience and [ __ ] but
I see you every night and you are I have
nothing but love for you because you are
so [ __ ] perfect in clerks three
like absolutely [ __ ] perfect every
moment you're golden on the screen every
time you come in you [ __ ] make people
laugh and [ __ ] oh it's [ __ ]
phenomenal
yes
sorry Jordan sorry Jordan saying some I
mean I don't know again I thought she
was going in the house babe that's why I
came in here sorry sorry
we should show baby
come here please being that you just
came in and there's been a distraction
or disruption or something we might as
well show them this camera bro she ain't
gonna want this mom want to see the see
the belly put on camera right now yeah
she knows she's on camera yeah
the whole audience Jordan the belly I'm
trying to do it in a a pleasant way but
look at this look at that baby belly
yeah so um see in the video
live as we speak right now
thank you baby
yeah sorry guys because she came in
because I guess I'm louder I didn't
realize in here it's hard to explain
guys because again you can't visually
see but but thank you you were talking
about the movie and how it comes on but
I cannot believe I knew you were I knew
it was coming to a close but I didn't
realize it was coming to a two-day uh
two more dates
close I mean that is four dates I have
two weeks down before those dates though
okay I have two weeks off but during
that time like is this mod Castle Film
Festival from November 30th to December
4th and I go to Boston December 5th
Hartford December 6th I go to Los
Angeles December 7th for living Josh's
movie wrong reasons yeah
that's when you have to want to do
another you have to come here well
hopefully you can come here we can
record in person and then I come to
Jersey hopefully yeah
when I'm in Los Angeles yeah so we could
do a couple more before that then we
should have like a Christmas special
well speaking of which you are going to
be coming to New Jersey
uh 12 11. I think we're gonna do Sal and
Bob get old it's mod castle and then on
12 12. I'm doing and you'll be there for
some part of it uh a promotion at the
secret stash called the 12 hours of
Christmas that we're doing with the
pops for next door pop freak and so we
get on the what the what not app oh yeah
we've done that at the cons and stuff
yeah it's like a live auction site kids
and so uh we'll be doing that for like
12 hours straight like a Telethon and
[ __ ] so it's an hour at the stash and
then an hour at Pop freak they do an
hour and then they come back to us for
an hour and then they go to them for now
so we'll start at seven in the morning
and go to like seven at night or
something like that
sell sell sell for Christmas season
season bunch of sad stuff exclusive
stuff so when you're out here for that
we'll record some more as well
so where you're at right now I have not
seen this uh when I was there last where
you're at the uh apartment uh movie
theater apartment
um
it was empty so right now you have now a
new desk you have a chair and uh there's
no this is just the table that was here
cool there's some furniture coming but
um yeah no same old same old okay but
on the floor like a [ __ ] college kid
I love it but from here it's cool
because with the sign and the the way
you have it and there's some I don't see
a mic or headset it sounds like you're
telling you where you forget we're an
audio podcast not a video podcast
stop explaining [ __ ] part of the podcast
my friend who are you Joe Rogan I'm
catching up no watching your podcast I
guess I'm doing it more for my benefit
because you and I haven't seen each
other in a few and I haven't been there
and you haven't been here so I'm
catching up on us let's get down to
business which is some [ __ ] content
me and this [ __ ] had a [ __ ] fight
last week and when I say fight I mean he
had a fight at me and [ __ ] hung up in
my [ __ ] face so let me set up the
story for you kids I'm talking not to
Jason Muse who I talk to only when we do
podcasts
I talked to Jason's wife Jordan uh our
boss like multiple times every day she
is probably the person that I speak with
most in life so I'm on a conversation
with Jordan and uh Jordan had texted me
to be like
did you this requires me to tell so many
stories while on the road kids and
Jason's gonna hate that I tell this but
like it could always be cut out but it
won't be
um on the road I you know we were on the
road a lot of driving I'm a I'm a very
I call it Jersey driver
and as far as I'm concerned so is Mr
Jason Muse who drives like I do but
Jason
um within the last year or two finally
said he's like I don't want to drive
with you anymore and he was the last
holdout most people don't want to drive
with me
um but Jason I always thought I could
count on and want to drive with me but
even he got it put to a place where he's
like you are unnecessarily Reckless and
that's saying something because he's one
of the speediest drivers I know in his
[ __ ] Elon [ __ ] so
um
while I've been on the road for the
tour for the convenience tour
uh there has been a time or
perhaps too that uh
um reckless driving
my reckless driving there's a big
question as to whether I should have
been driving on the tour at all or no
but my I love to drive and it was my car
on tour
so
um some of my reckless driving
tailgating speeding
got us into a position to be pulled over
and you know
I'm a man who enjoys the greens
and
you know that
is not necessarily a problem in some
states and in some states it's a big
deal
so let's say you know I ran into a
piccadillo or two along the way and
states that aren't green friendly or
whatnot but it all worked out at the end
of the day
um
a long time ago it was an old story
which I told
um I was traveling from Illinois to
Bloomington Indiana go do a show at a
comedy club and I was watching John
Oliver on my [ __ ] phone but it was
hung from my rearview mirror
and so I got pulled over for that
because you're not allowed to you know
[ __ ] have something distracting you
on your rear view mirror I guess
um it was a long drive but um that was
no excuse and uh when they pulled me
over they were like uh how much weed
have you smoked today and I was like
well I'll be honest I took a hit before
I left Illinois but I haven't smoked
that since then can we search the car
and I was like absolutely they went in
the car and they found like four joints
like they have smoked each one of them
in in in doob tubes and stuff and
they're like look like we're here
looking for
pounds kilos of weed like this is
nothing so we can either bring in and
write you up for these four half joints
or you could throw them out right here
on the side of the road and I was like
that sounds like a capital idea
um you know
is that because I've been in the movies
or is that because they're like it's a
hassle for [ __ ] four half joints or
you know even more recently I was pulled
over in a similar situation and there
was just a lot of you know pre-rolls and
and we get given them on the road all
the time people were like we love you
and they give you weed and it can't be
like I can't accept it
I think you put in a bag it comes with
you
but when you're in a state when like
weed's not quite legal
that could be a problem if you could
pull there so
I did and once again like things worked
out
um and I told Jordan like shortly after
what had happened and she was like don't
tell that story
but when we got to the place we were
going in Oklahoma
I a bunch of people were waiting on us
we were an hour and a half late so I did
tell the story but I was so super
careful to be like
don't you know [ __ ] talk about this
don't record this I saw phones I was
like I ain't talking till the phones are
down and stuff
and then kind of told the nutshell story
and stuff
so
Jordan text me the other morning and
she's like did you talk about that story
publicly
and so rather than write it all out I
called her and I was like yeah I told
you that I said it at the comic store
she's like you didn't tell me that I
told you not to tell that story I was
like yeah but I had to tell the people
at the comical questions bookstore and I
made sure that nobody
like shot it or anything she's like and
that's the only place you told her I was
like yeah I didn't tell it anyplace else
and she goes they're running a story on
TMZ
and for a second I got scared because
I'm like and then I'm like wait a second
so TMZ is going to run a story that said
Kevin Smith had weed on him like that's
great for the brand like that's you know
what in other dudes water is wet like I
don't think that's gonna shock anybody
so at the end of the day like why am I
getting upset and she was making me
upset like making me like go like am I
in trouble and [ __ ] that's my trigger
thinking like I'm in trouble somehow so
I was trying to understand why she was
getting tight about it like because she
kept saying this reflects on me somehow
and I was like trying to get to the
bottom of that so I kept asking her the
question but not like how does it
reflect on you but I'm like Jordan I
don't I'm am I missing part of the story
how does this come back to you or
whatever so we were talking about it and
Jordan's getting
you know Jordan's not emotional at all
but she's like coming from this place
where she's like you're being Reckless
and you know she she knows some stuff
going on in my life she's like you're
and you're being Reckless right now and
that's the worst place for you to be and
you need to stop you need to let the
kids drive and and blah blah and I was
like hey man like I just like had a bad
conversation like I don't need a lecture
right now and out of nowhere
I didn't even know he was there I
thought I was just talking to Jordan all
of a sudden I hear this [ __ ] scumbag
grab the phone and go like you're being
Reckless and we just care about you bro
and he [ __ ] hung up
and I was like what the [ __ ] happened I
texted Jordan I was like look I'm real
sorry that I may have set y'all off I I
honestly value you and your opinion I'll
stop driving slow fast I I you know
please like you feel free to call me
back but Jordan called me back and she
was like I didn't do that that was
[ __ ] him but I know Jason and it was
Jason on the verge of the tears like
almost emotional Jason so he wasn't
being a dick about it he felt that [ __ ]
but since he [ __ ] chose to [ __ ]
let it out at the most hissy-fit way oh
my God it was it was
but um but Jordan called back and we
talked for like two hours and [ __ ] Jason
interestingly enough did not call back
and nor did he ever be like yeah hey bro
I might have overreacted and I shouldn't
have hung up on you and [ __ ]
well I turn it up when I see you it's I
don't know I'm bad at texting I realize
texts come out
um they could come out so different than
what the meaning is especially for me
because I'm not very good at writing
like the cat ran dot or period whatever
exclamation point comma you know it's
like mine runs on and I know sometimes
she'll be like what and I'm like sorry
let me call you and tell you he's not
good with grammar or punctuation
it's like when I get texts from my
mother she uses the talk text feature so
it's one long [ __ ] sentence and words
words are approximate and stuff like
that and she don't read it and double
check it before she lets it go yeah no
it's and so I just figured eventually
I'll sing I'll see you and I'll tell you
in person I knew we were going to talk
soon
um
no apology or nothing like that but it
was very like you know I can count on
one hand the amount of times that this
[ __ ] has
like you know launched at me and that
was one of them and so you and no it
must mean that a great deal to them yeah
to get like [ __ ] tight like that
because he's not there's a guy who
doesn't give a [ __ ] he's like you do
what you want he's the ultimate Patriot
the ultimate America I don't mean
Patriot in as much as like America [ __ ]
yeah but he's the ultimate Patriot as
much as this country was founded on life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness and
that's what Jason believes in he don't
believe in telling people how to live
their lives he wants everybody to pursue
their own [ __ ] happiness so
least judgmental person I've ever met
least [ __ ] shitty done hung out hang
up on people for him to get to the place
where he got clearly
um he felt that I was being reckless in
my driving and has felt it for quite
some time
sometimes sometimes
um
um what I want to say oh so have you so
you got two weeks and have you been to
the store have you been to the store now
uh because it's right there yeah
yeah I just feel like it's something I
miss about being home I go to it all the
time bro you do how you have been great
I went over and saw him the other day
met a masquerade number three came out
we got the exclusive covers but I went
tagged a bunch tagged more quick stops
number one selling out like crazy so
like even the expensive [ __ ] books
like we had covers I wish I could get
you the covers to the the all red covers
man because uh we got only a hundred of
that book and that's the cover that they
did for Things From Another World that
Mike Allred did so it's like
if I tag it it's a 35 book we have both
tagged it would have been a 50 book that
book's [ __ ] selling man like it's
crazy the ultimate cover has been very
nice
um but yeah I go to the stash regularly
son go to our store regularly
yeah
we're talking about doing on the whatnot
day
since we're an hour on camera I'm an
hour on camera selling [ __ ] and then an
hour goes over to pop free on our down
arrow we're talking about doing photo
sessions with fans for the holidays me
you and mubi Christmas movie Santa movie
oh all right all right
so we can do that and then we can record
I think then while we're there we can uh
then we're doing we'll do our very first
chains on Bob get old
um at smodcast we won't do Father's Day
it's mod Castle
for later on down the road but we'll do
Jay and Son Bob get old that's my castle
read the scripts have a good ass time
and [ __ ] I love that I love that I'm
excited I honestly am
um because I come from doing my amusing
stories then I go to Jersey and then
I'll be going back
um but yeah man it's it's I'm excited
again this is the tough part now though
is is I realized it was already it's
been tough again you mentioning that
tour is almost done
um it's like I'm bummed because I feel
like you know I got to go on so much of
the last one and this one I didn't and I
could have but I'm saying I didn't
because a Logan and Jordan but then add
the element of the bit the new baby so
um but again six and a half it's coming
it's coming so I'm very excited what
February February yeah February 25th the
date I'm glad people seem to be on my
you know people been reaching out to me
um on my my twitch and stuff people that
have read the I mean listen to the first
and second episode which I think was
very awesome uh I'll tell you [ __ ]
you've got covered in People magazine
you're [ __ ] no I'm pregnant they were
like Jason Muse having a [ __ ] baby
boy yeah they covered you man it was
very cool very cool off of mostly off of
your Instagram post
yeah no that was again that was that was
really awesome and uh I think I wasn't
ready for that like I didn't plan on it
and it's one of those things where
you're like dang if only I knew it's
good because
um
again it's that was really unexpected
and the podcast I mean again I feel like
we we us talking about the amount the
first one the second one again now I
feel like we have with this one I really
um something I didn't realize you're
going to talk about and figure out our
names but I also wanted to tell a couple
funny stories but I'm afraid I'm gonna
get into the story
um because something I realized that's
been happening since the last
month or so is how much
um I can watch the time so I can make
sure the story goes is how short uh how
much how often Jordan is like come lay
with me I'm lonely and I'm like well
well well right but what I realized is
I've been getting distracted because now
that she has this belly she'll like lays
down on me should be sitting and not so
late forward and also I'm like oh my God
she's crushing the baby
and I'm picturing like her belly pushing
on my belly and it's like the baby's in
like a balloon you know like think about
if you had like a a stuffed animal
inside of a balloon right and you start
pushing the balloon sideways the the
balloon would start to get pushed like
this
miracle that you had to go like think of
a stuffed animal in a balloon as opposed
to think of a baby and a woman's womb
visually I could be hard you can't see
through a a woman doing everybody
everybody
yeah they show that half picture all the
time what a woman looks like with a baby
in her chair you're absolutely right
when you're having sex
late in the pregnancy there's a fear
that like if I go deep is it gonna poke
the baby in the eye and no such thing
right elsewhere then I was like yo can
you spend get like don't lay down on me
lay on your back so that I'm not there's
no pressure on your belly but then we
are going half half half whole have half
home and she started moving like this so
then I'm like oh [ __ ] the baby's being
shook up in there and she's getting cars
sick he's getting car sick in there and
then I was then I was like oh my God
what if like the umbilical cords
floating around in there because I'm
shaking them the umbilical cord starts
wrapping around his neck so yeah I've
been having like zone right can I tell
you that all this comes from a place
where you're like I am so good at
[ __ ] what if I [ __ ] the umbilical
cord around the kid's neck
and really I've seen you [ __ ] I've seen
it on tape it's like
that's right Ross and he's out kids no
that baby's fine and yeah he has a baby
has bigger problems than like you know
Jordan [ __ ] sits down to take a [ __ ]
gets up and down really quick it's going
to take a [ __ ] yes otherwise it's I
can't she might just pop out and [ __ ]
again we'll never say man in fact if I
remember correctly he's going back many
years Harley is now 23. but um Jen's a
gynecologist told us to like keep having
sex as much sex as possible particularly
late in the trimester because
um
there's a an agent in a secret agent in
um in semen that makes
you know induces labor oh okay so I bet
you I bet you're her gynecologist would
be like you know if you guys she she had
the baby naturally last time even no
drugs or nothing right oh yeah yeah and
that's definitely the plan this time too
again so so that so that'll help loosen
[ __ ] up when it's time like on the day
we we had scheduled Harley's
first Jen had gone past her due date and
so the doctor was like I'm picking this
day and we're doing it and she told me
like before you
before you come in amen oh yeah okay
look how loose is your goose
I must have the Plus
uh it was uh but that was an education
man knowing that there's something in
sperm that
makes makes the inducing then they put
some cream on it once you got in there
as well and then she was like ready to
go and then they gave her spinal she got
the spinal shot so like she couldn't
feel anything thank God but Jordan never
got the spinal man she just goes she's
like
um
[Music]
she's like I'm dogs that happens man you
know childbirth being imagine there's a
chance that like [ __ ] you're pushing
so hard you [ __ ] poop that's why they
want you to like clean your like [ __ ]
self off like you know [ __ ] [ __ ] as
much as you can at home before [ __ ]
began
[ __ ] no I I you know what it went it
went pretty smooth lost and we did right
on the due date last time last time it
was she was uh Logan was due April 1st
um and she was born on April 1st like
seven in the morning 6 30 in the morning
so
um
I bet you Jordan's got a different story
she's like a [ __ ] hurt like hell oh
no I'm not saying it didn't hurt I'm
just saying if the date and time was
like I was she told me she's like shut
up and sit in the corner hello
so I thought I I thought I heard my kid
Go Daddy
um but yeah
to what she's like stop telling stories
about Mom yeah she's like she did poop
you liar and that is the kind of thing
to Fascinate Logan Logan would be like
what do you mean she pooped while she
would love it she's like I hope none of
that poop got a man when I came out
she goes around writing all over it's
funny all over the house poop head daddy
is a poop head and then she'll be like
come here come here I wrote you
something and she'll have this cute
little picture on the front and then you
open up the card and it's like you are
poop you know and she loves calling me
poop can you please cut the Dogs Out
oh my God it's Jay's version of chege
yeah yeah okay join me in Jersey
yeah is he in there right now in the
house very cool she's sleeping in the
bed it's very sweet she's been out here
before she was out here when we shot
clerks through but
it's the first time at the movie theater
and she's fascinated by the whole thing
oh I bet she's like popcorn popcorn um
movie theaters closed on Monday and
Tuesday it'll probably change as we go
forward in 2023 but uh the Atlantic
movie house that their schedule was five
days a week so we're honoring that until
the new year begins
um but so it's closed downstairs and
it's also 10 55 anyway so the last show
would be out but Josh and Liv since I
was like I was like I'm gonna record a
podcast with Muse they were like all
right we'll go downstairs and watch a
movie and they're watching wakanda
forever right now oh okay and that's fun
they had their food they ordered a bunch
of food from the pizza place in Red Bank
and they took it all downstairs and
we're doing Thanksgiving there
um
and on Thursday we're doing like [ __ ]
friends giving so each of us is going to
make something like I'm making hummus
and french toast and Josh is making like
a side Tam roll Liz making the um a
coconut custard pie she's making uh
Frito pie and uh then we're gonna lay
out a table in front of the front row in
the theater one and then
um we spread it we bought tablecloths so
we spread the meal out there we sit in
the front row and then we're gonna watch
mystery signs three thousand like a
couple episodes of that
um then we're gonna start picking off
lists that films on the list that lives
got that we've been talking about for a
while like oh you should watch this we
should watch this
um so we're gonna watch
not just Mystery Science Theater
uh 3 000 but
um probably let me see Tootsie
let's list
um just a bunch of [ __ ] like put up some
[ __ ] on a big screen and watch movies
all Thanksgiving so that sounds like a
plan that's how we're doing Thanksgiving
on uh the East Coast here
smodcast Castle uh on the west coast uh
Harley and barnegal in Austin are going
to Disneyland
oh yeah that's how they're doing a
holiday Thanksgiving
um but uh yeah first one apart in a long
time be interesting weird but
yeah
but you know I we're speaking of you
know our subject of course is
being a father
and uh Jason
uh his father to uh Logan a little girl
of seven nearly eight and he's about to
be a dad to
who I'm hoping will be named Magnus Muse
Magnus baby Magnus Muse that's my vote
for the name
um
uh but uh I'm a dad of Harley Quinn
who's like 23 and the dad job never
stops kids don't matter how old they get
Dad for life
um yes and I Got to Be an Effective dad
this week uh because she had a
a week of like bad news after bad news
and
you know I'm Mr
Sunshine positivity and hope and stuff
and I was able to kind of come in and
give some healthy life perspective and
stuff but
the dad never stopped man
she uh
she was very sweet she was like you're
really
you really always know what to say and
I'm like well take it with a grain of
salt I'm a writer
um I hear one right now sorry to
interrupt your oh spring yes baby
baby you gotta come in here
what
Jax is not in here but will you come say
hi to Uncle Kevin
do you want he should be in there come
sad Uncle Kevin
where are you at home little pink sugar
heart she might need this here baby
watch your feet
um
yeah so baby remember you're on a chair
and it doesn't really
it's hard to see that
oh she can't hold on
hello little pink sugarheart how are you
I want to I don't know it'll be really
loud for that so how are you kiddo
good
what's going on with them teeth
they're growing in there what happened
did the little did the baby boy in mom's
belly kick them teeth out no there's a
horse there's a whole story to it is
there really what is the story I got
time the first one which was this one
yeah um it
I was I wanted to take it out but I was
it was really time for school so I had
to take it out and then when Mom and my
mommy was taking was trying to get the
string off it she pulled my tooth she
yanked my tooth up
on accident did it hurt
uh oh not that much but then the second
tooth was really funny I was eating
Lucifer's pizza and I um it twisted all
the way around and then I went out and
then I bit into a piece of pizza and
it's not like the tooth got caught in
the pizza but it almost did it got
caught in my hand oh God you're gonna
make me throw up I'm not good with stuff
like this that was squeamish
um let me tell you something right now
if you need me to call the cops
on Mom or Dad if they're knocking your
teeth out
you you blink like this twice go blink
your eyes real hard twice to send me the
message that you're like yes I need to
be rescued they're taking my teeth did
you put your teeth under a pillow yeah
we have a video of it get out of here
how much you make
the first time it was 50 and then it was
um this tooth was twenty dollars and
then the other one was twenty dollars so
now I have eighty dollars
because the first tooth these two they
gave me 40 so 40 plus 40 is 80. yeah now
I have now I have eighty dollars when I
was a kid the tooth fairy and I lost a
tooth tooth fairy give me a quarter
yeah usually
um
Grandma Gail she said that she got one
dollar
she got a dollar and she's an old lady
her tooth fairy must have been Rich
how's school
I had Thanksgiving dinner at school
in Francaise
everybody everybody was talking English
even Tsum
which is she's my French teacher let me
uh give us a sentence or two in French
let's hear you speak French fluently
wait which one the first or the second
whatever one has more to it so he can
really get you but yeah I forgot the
last part oh yeah we didn't do the other
one then
why wait this is a
um a Halloween one well close
um wait she's at the wait don't
inclusions
means butt
means like behind you and it means your
butt I always thought it was derriere
but it's down yeah
you have to have an accent yeah yeah
yes yes
but we can't find jacks
oh what happened Jax for those who don't
know Jax is their second dog
David
bye sugarheart thank you for the time
bye say one more thing in French one
more thing in French
you're a Norman Rockwell portrait of
[ __ ] Americana right there
um every night on uh not every night but
most nights when I'm on the court we
wind up talking about what I'm doing in
the future and uh I tell them like you
know this is my 15th movie as a director
and
you know um you know I know what the
next five movies are do you want to know
what they are I go through a list and
I'm always like the 20th movie we can't
start shooting
for 10 years and we gotta wait 10 years
for our third lead
to be old enough and you know I was like
I realized
recently that like with clerks three I
have an indie film Trilogy and I'm like
now I want more trilogies and
uh you know I have two Jay and Silent
Bob movies so I'm within Striking
Distance of a Jane Silent Bob trilogy
so
I said when we were on set of Jane Sal
and Bob reboot you know I was like how
weird Harley was a baby in jail strike
back and then Jay and Silent Bob reboot
she's the third lead and here's Logan on
Jay and Silent Bob reboot as her first
movie
like I was like so if we follow the
pattern
we have to make one more of these and
Logan gets to be the third lead just
like Harley was the third lead
reboot and I was like by that point
Harley would be old enough her character
Millie to have her own daughter so
Millie Millie's daughter Harley Logan
will play Harley's daughter in the movie
which means that we'll go on an
adventure with [ __ ] Logan and stuff
but that means that Jay's daughter will
be playing Jay's granddaughter in the
movie and that's that's how she'll start
her career with an adorable story for
the Press about how she's [ __ ]
playing her dad her grand her father's
granddaughter even though
[ __ ] that's what we call acting
around here
I like it I'm talking about how adorable
she was just think what she'll be like
in 10 [ __ ] years I told Jordan today
I was like that kid's amazing but you
gotta watch out for her because she's as
smart as her mother and as crafty as her
father
Harley still laughs at a story that
Logan told she was like one day Logan
was talking she loves Logan she thinks
she's fascinated Logan told her one day
she's like
they don't let me watch YouTube but when
my dad's asleep I take his phone and I
hold it up to his face and then I watch
YouTube yeah yeah I was like holy [ __ ]
that's the Muse level crafty right there
she's uh she's like Jordan has woken me
up I've fallen asleep and Jordan has
come in because to be like hey you fell
asleep in her bed to wake me up and then
she'll like find like me sleeping and
and Logan sitting there watching uh
YouTube but it's the good thing is she's
really been into right now these art
this art girl which is very interesting
but uh I don't know it's we went to the
this picnic today at her school for
thanks I guess just Thanksgiving
Gathering uh and just to watch all the
kids and
how they interact with each other and
stuff already at seven eight years old
is it's uh yeah it's very interesting
it's not what I expected and then
there's one of uh Jordan's friends well
I guess our friend family friend she
just had a two week her baby's two weeks
old little boy so she brought him there
and so I was holding him and he's just
so tiny and I just I forgot and I just
can't wait like I honestly I'm very
excited about the the new baby I think
it's gonna be a lot of work more more
work on top of what we have going on
already with me traveling and and all
that stuff
um but it's gonna be very amazing and
and uh yeah so I wanted to ask you here
on bit of that baby
baby boy and you let's talk about them
names
yes I have one I wanted to ask you what
you thought fireworks two so one of the
things we were thinking again we like a
lot of names people have suggested such
we're another conclusion or I guess
that's the word that we've come to us it
would be awesome if somehow we can it's
Jordan Muse Jason Muse jmjm
Logan Ling Muse
Lex Lee Muse or Luther Lee Muse
what do you think of Lex not together
but one or the other Lex or Alexander it
would be Lex straight up Lex
really yeah so just an idea Lex or
separately why can't it be like the
reviews
it could it could technically but it
technically we should be throwing Lee in
the middle there because it's a
tradition in the family but it could be
changed for something perfect I feel
like if it's got to be me in the middle
name then it's Jason Lee Muse right
there oh yeah let's go
I like it Stanley Jason Lee
Muse holy [ __ ] it would be tough it'd be
tough if Jason Lee is great Stanley if
you tell me tell me you think you've got
a People magazine article
out of [ __ ] you know being like we're
having a baby you name that kid Stan Lee
Muse oh the whole world writes about it
the whole world welcomes his birth so
look finally another Stan Lee he's
honoring great Stanley he named his
whole human child say no dog that you're
naming Stan Lee it's a [ __ ] child
Stanley and it's a yeah and what if he
it's like reincarnated I'll send a 12
year old
Stanley Muse creates spider bug no I
don't know something new though what if
his first word is Excelsior whoa yeah
I'm telling you they never know that
like what if he actually was like a
genius he created like like we know what
we know now of Spider-Man and the in The
Avengers heart the everything how big
and popular it is something he created
so many years ago just think about it he
could create something that like was
like 90. yeah and like I'll tell you
what right now you name your kid Stanley
Muse he's definitely getting a job at
Marvel
oh
damn we're working for Disney son
yeah hell yeah all right
a backup so what else but what what
other so I like like you said I like
Magnus we're liking I still also like
Azrael I like Azrael but yeah Jordan's a
big fan of asriel as well Azrael uh you
know in our world Azrael was uh Jason
Lee's character
in uh
um
pulled the name from Angelic lore and
and Jordan's got a deep dive on the name
and
she likes it quite a bit she sounds like
she's [ __ ] turning Muse around on it
when he knows damn well the kids should
be named either Magnus Muse yeah or now
my number one [ __ ] favorite Stan Lee
Muse oh okay oh yeah you know I like him
hey I'm I'm uh
and can you live with a kid named Stan
that's the problem that's the problem
you could call him a bunch of nicknames
you could call them [ __ ] Excelsior
you could call him nuff said yeah call
him Xavier call them any Marvel
character yeah yeah yeah that's true he
has like a [ __ ] uh rotatable name
um
Lieberman oh Stanley Lieberman that was
Stan's name yes you're right you're
right okay we can just call him little
man Muse baby boy Muse
Lieber Lieberman Lieberman it's there's
so many like but again I'm not against
it but if there's more than one
convincing and again the problem is I
don't think of the full name is amazing
from but I think of again I told Jordan
she makes fun of me but what how I
always try to think in my head about a
name is them run like my little man
running through the playground with his
friends and they're like yo Stan Lee you
know hey yo Magnus
hey yo Xavier get over here like this
shout out
like mags yo Maggie
so so it's uh it I always think as long
as you could say it like if it like
mine's still playing right like Jason
come here Jason Edward get your butt
over here hey tiger no I'm just kidding
I had Kevin Patrick Kevin Patrick oh
[ __ ] that she'd be like Kevin Patrick
one yeah
so I I think it'd be called lose again
there's there's a bunch but I would love
for after this episode you get the
double hit of Lex Luthor and and Luther
the [ __ ] series with uh yeah well
Luther Vandross a little Anita
convenient
too
and that's my fault
um so I don't know there's there's some
good ones there's some good ones uh but
yeah I wish uh
I wonder if we could play some kind of I
want people to send stuff in if they
listen to this episode and then somehow
we could tie in that with that like
maybe they they uh
oh I don't know people send in names and
when we pick the name we've crochet a
blanket with the name on it we do like a
you know they do like the baby balloon
parties I don't know I don't know so
Forest get burned down and people die
gender reveal party and they don't even
want that anymore because you can't pick
your kids gender right yeah yeah you
have to be like
sex
like announcement party or something
yeah yeah I guess what you're saying
well I'm saying more so that we put the
I want to just put something on a
blanket a name I guess mine would be a
name reveal uh thing and not even a
party it'd be more of like a hey let me
tell you here on Father's Day episode
five
okay right now I know your lady pretty
well
there's no way on Earth she's gonna let
the public decide
that's true that's true but that but
someone could get close it's almost like
gambling like pick a number one to a
hundred
so when it comes down though we could be
like the winner is well I'll play it
right now we can skew this contest by
saying
that she heavily favors Azrael to win
uh all right wait no or yeah that means
the odds are pretty hard okay
you can make money off this
we do a little OTB with some off-track
betting and [ __ ] wait what is it oh off
to the side and [ __ ] I'm like place your
bets place your bets yeah how much money
you've got a side hustle bet going and
then you screw everything by [ __ ]
like you got 101 odds on [ __ ] Stanley
Muse and then you pull it out at the end
and you you're a better
101 101 odds we can have odds and
everything right and then we can add if
we could take a Dodge
someone that would joined fix a name by
line that's taking a diverse
yeah that's the Integrity that we have
here on Father's Day I'm gonna make some
side money off of this
no we want to do that but I I think it'd
be fun would not we wouldn't do it kids
but the fact that he thought of it all
shows you that we are from New Jersey
the fact that I was willing to co-sign
it we're just shading up where it's like
you know what if it fell off the truck
you know yeah yeah I'm scared it's not
like stealing I didn't steal it
I've just found it
[Laughter]
um there's your [ __ ] Father's Day
kids what an adventure we had we still
don't know the baby's name we do know
the baby sex we got to talk to Logan
who's just [ __ ] fascinating
um
and uh you've heard some [ __ ] Tales
you heard about a wicked fight between a
couple dads dad
and we're gonna get ads going at it in
the goddamn driveway and [ __ ] oh my
goodness it's yeah it's again we uh it's
not often that it happens but I do feel
like eventually we'll we'll have this is
great but I I can't wait uh and people
out there if anyone's like well they
talked about this and that we're gonna
have uh I want to come up with some
segments some I'm gonna come up with
some ideas from here when I see you in
person I want to sit down and be like
hey how about this how about we start
with this and then we play a game like
this called let us father
let us fathers
um you want to come up with this many
departments as you want please do uh I
would like to suggest one yes please
based on what we just did we got to give
Logan 10 minutes every week oh I love it
okay done and done and even if we're in
person and she's if I'm in Jersey and
she's not here we could call her which
is even we'll be sort of funny because
we can
at that very talkative age where she
wants to tell you a story about
everything and all the details are like
[ __ ] delicious no I love it with
missing two front teeth it's [ __ ] I
know no we definitely we well we
definitely will so again she because
she'll be home because she'll be home
from school and we'll make sure it's
earlier and we'll definitely call her if
when I'm in Jersey and we're in person
she'll be here of course but we'll be
able to call her and we can talk with
her and make sure it's planned out and
stuff uh she can sit in front of my
computer I love it man I love it great
idea so I hope so I'll see you the next
time I see you and you guys will get
another episode will be
next week
yeah I keep forgetting I can't remember
if I keep forgetting if you're coming
here first or I'm going there first and
then regardless we're on a schedule yes
I love it but we uh as far as this show
goes uh Happy Thanksgiving
and Father's Day isn't that weird a
holiday wishing another holiday yes
happy holidays Happy Thanksgiving from
Father's day you'll only hear that here
on Father's Day with Jay and Son Bob
um thanks for listening kids to a couple
of dads dad knit yes can
um for Father's Day I'm Kevin Smith
Jason Muse
um Happy Father's Day everybody
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]